will we going into the second season
with shelter get to in a couple years
but it uh we the episodes are 20 minutes
bro like how am I gonna get through this
you know what I mean he's been weeping
over the queen died
you mean Diana he just found out about
that yeah Diana dude that was crazy
most of the Muslims in America are black
and so we wanted to put black Muslims on
the show we got rehearsal Ali in the
second season he's great and yeah and so
and and my character yeah uh Mary's his
daughter who yeah so we were excited to
explore those storylines I realized how
famous you are based on who comes on
your show and who mershali Bella Hadid
Mia Khalifa and I'm like this
motherfucker's crazy famous
she's well known yeah yeah hey can I ask
you a question about Mia Khalifa yes
I went and seen my aunt in three years
and the first thing she says to me is
Mia Khalifa huh
this is my aunt's in Cairo is she like
disappointed or intrigued curious oh
I get the disappointment yeah because
she's Catholic so that's not her [ __ ] to
wear in the porn what you didn't know
this no are you doing an Andrew thing
yeah I'm right tell him I'm right
you don't know I don't think I would
ever say you were right but
that would be a a crazy position to take
but I I get what you're saying like I
understand the backlash right right
right because I think the the Western
version of it is like oh this woman's
name is Mia Khalifa so she must be
Muslim right yeah because a lot of times
we don't realize that there are Catholic
Muslims right Catholic Muslims I said it
and keep it in I said it double dip it
in Double Down Catholic Middle Eastern
folks okay
and uh so she's wearing the hijab and
the porn and I get it if you're a Muslim
you're like yo you this isn't even your
[ __ ] like if you were Muslim and devout
and you want to porn it up okay but
you're putting on uh you know Muslim
face
she's wearing slim face I'm just
thinking about Catholic Muslims like
just like like a Christmas without food
[Laughter]
uh she came on our show really just very
sweet person now when you were praying
because I know you guys will pray during
filming yeah did she know what to do we
we did no we were that was it was
separate or was she like me where it's
like okay you guys do your thing I'll
see you in about 15 minutes pray with
them no I wasn't even invited you
you know he prays before we eat he was
doing that he was all this time you're
not Muslim
everything unveiled
half of the flagrant
turns out none of them are somehow
Schultz knows the Moose
he's supposed to be Muslim Christian
atheist yeah